yo what's up guys it's prestige and
today I'll be doing a seed spotlight on
a few seeds that I thought were pretty
cool if you like any of the season
particularly make sure to let me know in
the comments so that I can do a whole
seed spotlight video on one of the seeds
get very in-depth into it since I'm
gonna just gonna be doing intros to all
of the seeds that you guys can check
them out at your own accord
hope you enjoy and let's happen oh yeah
and before this video keeps going the
seed of this is 59 just 5 9 I'll type in
chat by 9 and you just want to see for
sure 59 its I didn't say that in the
video and that's the entire point of
this is to show you the seat so
apologies that I didn't do it and I'm
doing it now but see this 59 number 5
not simplified alright so the first C
that we're gonna be looking at is the
ice peak see the ice hills I'm not sure
exactly what it's called actually I can
check the ice plain seed that you saw me
standing on one of the ice picks and the
intro and something I didn't cover in
the intro I am using the Steve skin it's
because I had some skin troubles while
trying to record I kept trying kept
crashing my computer so for this video
you'll see some vanilla Steve I
apologize if that really tears your eyes
though so as you can see this is the ice
Plains biome this is a pretty rare biome
I've never come across one in my vanilla
plane of Minecraft however I haven't
played too much of vanilla mining Club
craft while the ice planes have been in
the game they haven't been here for too
long they've been here for a good amount
of time though so it's a pretty cool you
spawn right in like where you saw me
start the video that's where you spawn
so you spawn right next to this biome
that the main draw to this seed is this
biome there is actually a good amount of
lava in this biome but just a really
sick biome in my opinion that's pretty
hilly so it's like mini extreme Hills
like medium Hills let's say yeah and
it's just these ice towers like most of
them are tree level and some them just
skyrocket like skyscrapers there and
there are just a bunch of cool mountain
shapes with the ice around in the ice by
them so I'll leave you guys with a few
just kind of scroll through I mean just
speed up the video and run through all
the ice so you guys can just get a nice
view of it and then we'll move on to the
next bottom so next up we have what I
think is my favorite survival island
seed I've seen yet it's a survival more
like a survival Mountain seed you can
see it spawns you right on the top of
that hill Mountain Hill small mountain
large hill and your spawn just in ocean
land isn't too far away if you're gonna
vote out but if you want to do a
survival island for light display or
just have an interesting time this is a
pretty cool different kind of different
survival island not just a mound of dirt
so let's get to see this one is actually
very long seed is 5 8 3 9 9 3 1 2 3 0 5
4 2 2 7 9 6 5
ohh if you can see that I'll try and put
it in my description that you guys can
just copy paste that so you don't have
to type it all out so now we're gonna
move to the third and final one see
finally we have our ending seed this one
spawns you want to kind of moderate area
nothing too special about a lot of
desert I'm actually recording this after
I record everything else cuz the
previous recording got a little messed
up so you noticed I actually have a skin
for this part go back to not having a
skin soon so the seed for this one is
seven nine eight six seven three four
zero zero one nine six one five two four
oh one long seed the significant parts
of the seeds that has a stronghold at
negative ten 4128 I actually including
the stronghold in this one because it's
an under water and rinse and I think
it's pretty cool it's probably the
coolest strong evidence I've seen before
there's a village and a temple and
negative 401
and other villages at the coordinates
you see there there's actually a second
deduct a temple in the year the second
village which is pretty good we're gonna
check out the this village and temple
come on show this stuff just because I
only have footage of that so and yeah
well we'll go to it now and we're here
so you see that there is the same temple
over there and there's the village over
here some glowstone markers just that I
remember that the villa the same temple
was there you can see we're at negative
for 1297 so right around I get a four
hundred 100 I actually haven't gone in
the village I just saw and marked up the
glowstone so I kind of want to see if
there's any good loop in the blacksmith
shop and I don't know if blacksmith shop
stuff is uh it's always the same loot or
different when you spawn there you the
bike Smith what you're not even bikes
before you in here
alright so alright alright some bread
some iron and uh iron pick and six of
city I think is pretty fine I don't look
them much but it's pretty good and then
get bookcases I don't I don't think I
see I didn't see a little Church thing
so I there there's probably no priests
where you can buy the special stuff but
there as well and they have us pretty
cool that's basically the village and
now we're gonna go over to the temple
after the temple head up be strong and
however was that ravine ooh triple as a
Tribble peach right here again I haven't
been here either so we're gonna
you're gonna not blow up I'm gonna not
blow everything up alright so there is
going to be like play this up there is
going to be the normal TMT that you can
loop if you don't blow this place up so
that's a bunch of TNT you can get I just
got a high CPUs crap
whatever zero so spire and gold bones
that since basic stuff more iron bones
slash iron gold and okay iron horse
armor iron horse armor is pretty good so
I said actually alright alright I just
wanted to get rid of the little messages
kind of annoying in the wait recording
session so yeah that's the temple kind
of we kind of glitched into the sand and
now I do want to check out this this
name this is like a baby there's
actually a lot of iron and polling here
so that's for being a baby ravine I
think that's pretty so baby ravine
didn't even think no was here because
I'm just a blind blind person no offense
applied view I'm not supplying alive and
yeah
so the lot lava pit and it's special so
we're gonna go hit up that stronghold so
all again jumpin past the desert and
some ocean you'll find if you're in
survival with the help of your ender
pearls the legitly made or if your
integrative like me with the ender
pearls that I just spawned in you'll
find the ender pearls will drop or right
here where you see all that glowstone
and where this posted marker is just let
you know it is that nate- thousand one
hundred stove so who else I was close
this close so you're gonna drop down
here and you see that you can see these
structure of the stronghold right here
which is pretty cool I think is pretty
cool and this is just like jutting out
and like that this like this is actually
this is the portal room so you can get
down here you see the poor this takes
you right to the portal
no hassle of anything else in the
stronghold you know always going to
explore the stronghold but this lets you
in right away so you get down here you
can throw your ender portals in and
go fight a dragon let's get rid of
silverfish so yeah it takes you right to
the ender portal and end portal I guess
not the ender portal it's all the end
isn't it hope you guys enjoy this video
I hope this skin wasn't too horrible to
look at whenever I went in to f5 mode
and yeah let me know if you enjoyed any
of the seeds specifically or if you have
any questions if the seeds not working
go and the seeds wrong and I don't know
how I would be able to but just in case
I did so did let me know chicken hi and
yeah hope you enjoyed it and I'll see
you guys next time peace out